now that the Super Bowl is over it's
time for the big game a labor battle
between NFL owners and NFL players if
the 2011 NFL season is completely
scrapped you can blame either side but
the real culprit here is government
meddling in what should be a purely
private process let's take a look at how
we got here the NFL Players Association
was formed in 1956 and was mostly
ignored by NFL owners until the Supreme
Court ruled that unlike Major League
Baseball the NFL could not be treated as
a single entity but as separate teams
subject to federal antitrust law that
means that league wide standards like a
salary cap were illegal because it would
be considered collusion between
competing entities with that out of the
way the NFL PA then petitioned the
National Labor Relations Board to become
a certified union giving them a
government-granted monopoly on
collective bargaining so these days NFL
players don't have the right to
negotiate their own contracts outside of
the union of course owners aren't at all
innocent when it comes to abusing
government intervention hundreds of
millions of public dollars have been
spent by local governments on stadium
construction over the years and now
owners are claiming that maintenance
costs on these lavish monstrosities have
become too burdensome so they voted to
opt out of the current collective
bargaining agreement now the union is
threatening to decertify because by
relinquishing their government-granted
status as a single bargaining entity
they can run back to the government and
sue owners for violating federal
antitrust laws let's check the replay
owners convince the government to make
taxpayers foot the bill for luxury
stadiums then claim the maintenance
costs are so high they have to opt out
of their contract with the government
approved Union who in turn threatens to
relinquish that government-granted
status so they can use government
created antitrust regulation to sue the
owners in federal court
regardless of who you're rooting for
this mess wouldn't exist without
government getting in the way hey Ref
let him play